guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added bavia Illinois
November 10th and 11th and closing out
the year at Cobbs in San Francisco
California December 8th and 9th get all
tickets at
ryanr I'm excited to announce that my
special Lefty sun is now available as an
audio album go check it out out
everywhere you get
music I'm very excited to announce that
the Honeydew video is now available on
Spotify it doesn't change anything for
you at all it's just an additional place
to watch the Honeydew go check out the
Honeydew audio and video now available
on
Spotify the Honeydew with Brian
sichler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sichler ryan.com Ryan
sichler on all your social media I want
to thank you as I do every week thank
you for being here thank you for
watching supporting subscribing if
you're new here if you've been here I
appreciate you all right if you're
looking for more and you got to have it
man every week have a patreon called the
Honeydew with y'all and it's this show
with y'all and y'all have the wildest
[__] stories I've ever heard in my
life if you're new here we have had cold
cases solved we've talked to people
who've died I've talked to a lady with
multiple [__] talk to one with
multiple [__] okay this episode's
already demonetized just by me saying
that so go support the patreon it's five
bucks a month all right you get the
Honeydew a day early you get it ad free
at no additional cost there's hundreds
of episodes over over there it costs
less than a penny for an episode all
right if you don't like it you
unsubscribe all right if you do love it
you subscribe for a year you get over a
month free if you're looking for a new
podcast to listen to go listen to my old
podcast to crab Feast the crab Feast
podcast I used to do a Jay Larson back
in the day I'm telling you that library
is going to do over a million downloads
this year that's [__] insane all
right there's a hardcore audience for it
and everyone you love in podcasting is
on there everybody sagora Christina B
bur they're all there great stories
different stories than you've heard
every anywhere else um and then if I'm
in your town when you're around come see
me on the road I will be in Salt Lake
City October 27th and 28th I'll be in
bavia Illinois November 10th and 11th
and I'll be closing out the year in San
Francisco I can't wait cobs December 8th
and 9th and that's it that's the biz you
guys know what we're doing over here we
highlight the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers very excited to have this
guest on first time here on the
honeydude ladies and gentlemen Troy B
welcome to the Honeydew Troy it was so
hard for me to stay quiet when you were
talking your voice is like honeydew as
soon as you you're listening to honeydew
podcast I got a little wet thank you man
one of my multiple [__] the one that
that's that stays dry so that's how you
know I call that one sandpaper yeah uh
no it's great to uh business [__] I got
that's my business [__] yeah oh yeah
that's the hardest one to the hardest
one they call it the Hillary Clinton
yeah the Hillary Clinton it's uh I love
getting to be on someone else's it's a
pants suit it's disgusting you put it
down there and it's yeah they call it
South of Bosnia [__] but it's I have a
podcast and it's great going to be on
someone else's just go and and it's
amazing thank you for having me thank
you for reaching out uh you described me
in a way that's become my legacy the
last year or so where you were like I
don't know what the guy's name is but I
want to have him on the podcast he's I
knew you were Troy Troy something which
is farther than I usually get
York and be like hey that guy told the
woman to shut the [__] up and it just
both looks like we're like yeah [__]
women we gave the right to vote in 1920
man um and then I'm like well that's my
that's that's it like got yeah Philly so
it was it meant a lot that you knew the
first name I saidy I'm like now his
name's Troy I was like he's the guy that
told that lady to [__] off that crazy
lady and I said you see him he's wearing
the Dark Shades and I said he looks like
he's got that Richard Bell Vibe he's got
that old school 7s boom and and then
then you told me that people told you
that why you stop watching yeah like I
can't wear I wear the glasses yesterday
and like I'm wearing a hat today um but
I wore the glasses and my after the show
I was I was wet and like I'm looking at
the meet and greet pictures on my
stories and I'm doing like the Cub brick
stare I look like Jack Nicholson in The
Shining I'm just like I have two girls
on my arm I'm like get into the picture
with the goblin uh so it's uh it's it's
great to just be on the other side of
the Pod cuz I got to interview people
all the time you got ask questions that
you don't like it's great to be able to
just well plug promote everything all my
road dates I'm on the road a lot um I
don't know when this is going to come
out but uh I you doing Wise Guys in Salt
Lake I am so good I was out there last
month I almost quit smoking when I was
out there cuz the air was so thin
cigarettes or weed uh oh I'm never stop
smoking weed okay God I how am I going
to go to sleep at night we that's what
I'm saying how am I going to do yeah do
I want food to not taste as delicious
great I'll stop smoking weed yesterday
um all my Road dates Troy Bond life.com
vaping that's what it was I Jewel that's
my problem I go I switch back and forth
between acoustic and electric cigarettes
um and uh when I was in salt electric
cigarettes that's great and I was in
Salt Lake and like it hurt my I felt it
in my lungs I was like why is it feels
like there's like I'm swallowing pine
cones and with my opener and she's like
the Air's a lot thinner up here and
you've been chain smoking and I'm like n
that can't be it I'm going to keep
smoking and not work on a control group
um so if you want to support my uh lung
cancer research come see me on the road
Troy Bond live.com all my social media
you've probably seen me on the toilet on
Tik Tok or Instagram uh Troy Bond
69 uh because Troy Bond 1 through 68 was
taken that's the only reason I chose 69
is that for real that's uh no it was um
it was Troy has Ebola for like 10 years
that was my that's my Twitter it's Troy
has Ebola still but then as I started to
gain more traction people thought my
last name was hasola so they were like
Troy has BL so I was like well booking
middle eastes
like money side and I'm like yeah I know
I'll get booked in Israel and Palestine
I don't care call that a two-state
booking solution I'm coming that Yahoo
bring hummus for everybody well I want
to say this because we're talking about
smoking so I ask you outside I'm like
you know what do you want to talk about
and you you drop right away something
that blew blew me away uh and I I want
you to say what you said but then I want
to rewind and we're going to lead up up
to it so say what you told me out there
I started smoking crack when I was 15
with my uncle your uncle a family member
not somebody in the neighbor with a hell
of a man that's how I did it with a with
a hero with a guy who knew was he your
dad's brother or mom's brother my dad's
brother um yeah let's go back to the
beginning where where are you from
originally I I was born in a town called
Waterberry Connecticut I grew up in ngat
which is right next to Waterberry um and
uh and are you an only child you have
sibl two younger siblings um one is a
Ultimate Fighter Is that real he really
is yeah um and is doing well he just had
his second knockout he knocked out
somebody for the second time last week
uh he was covered he posted an Instagram
story covered in blood and I was like
are you okay and he was like it's not my
blood and I was like that's the coolest
[__] ever man he actually came to a show
with me a couple of weeks ago and there
was a guy in the front row listen at our
job if ever covered in blood and we say
it ain't my blood and nothing cool about
that a woman threw ashes at me a couple
of weeks ago she threw her dead mother's
ashes at me it's on my Instagram she was
and then she was drunk and heckling
during 11:00 show and then I was like
what is your problem and then she was
like my mother died a couple weeks ago
and uh I'm here cuz I told her I was
going to sprinkle her ashes everywhere I
everywhere I had fun and then she walks
up to the state pulls out a Ziploc bag
of her mother a gram of Mom no at this
point
I like literally look into the camera go
why is nobody stopping This and like I
get off like that's going to be a great
clip I'm like I'm covered in dead [__]
right now I'm just like it was like was
like it like the soft Tower just
collapsed but instead it was just the
love of your mother I'm covered in from
head to toe I farted earlier and I like
felt like learning how to drive um and
if was that that's uh once you once you
have something like that and that's a
good day at work uh uh compared to like
what my my brother does uh where he gets
in the ring and fights everybody which I
look at it exhausting but he came to a
comedy show one night where I did like
five shows and and and in in a on a
Saturday you know that's what we do and
he was like I can't do what you do man
and I only do what I do once a month
like uh and so he does that he's a
fighter and then I got one who's uh in
college right now brother two younger
brothers for now um one who's in college
I think he's studying to be a therapist
or something I should probably find that
out just send him I need someone to yeah
uh I he's like coming to my show next
month and uh cuz I'm going to
Connecticut and I was like I don't know
if I want you sitting there cross
analyze me when you're 19 and you're
just starting to learn psychology you're
yeah just be like all right I do
remember dad doing that but I remember
the story very differently my brother um
so I grew up in Connecticut parents
together parents are uh I mean when you
grew up when I grew up they were
together yeah um uh and what did your
dad do for a living he uh for a a living
what your dad do to make
money uh he did a lot but he never made
any um my dad uh owned a karate school
he uh um was a wrestler and uh he was
also a DJ yeah I was saying this sound
so much and was and I asked you to
personal trainer as well personal
trainer motivational speaker I think his
job on Facebook I might know your dad
you know yeah it might I think yeah we
we have the same bill think it is um and
I grew up around that and my dad because
he was a DJ didn't listen to um music in
the car when we're driving the com we're
driving the wrestling gigs he would
listen to comedy albums just full L
music from work music and we would
listen to like you know fulllength Robin
Williams or Cosby or prior or uh
delirious or raw like you know the stuff
that he grew up on that I'm four five
years old probably younger than that
absorbing it as a kid and then I start
looking at the world through the lens of
a comic cuz that's how I that's how I
started I was seeing a lot of [__] four
or five years old old going from the
karate schools to the wrestling gigs to
uh all the all this eclectic stuff that
my life has sort of accumulated and now
I'm listening to Comedy all the time who
are that's how I'm understanding the
world you know what I mean like yeah
they're painting those pictures for you
now and you're like oh these things are
all making sense now yeah oh that was
illegal oh that was yeah all kinds of
[__] you start learning okay and it
really expedited um like the the chip in
your brain that processes information
for me uh like I feel like I gained
Consciousness at a younger age just
because like I was immediately looking
at things and observing them and trying
to make my own conclusions or drawing my
own conclusions from them um and then I
started seeing the World Through My Lens
and my dad also wanted to be a comic and
actor when I was when uh before he had
me um and then he didn't pull out so he
couldn't uh and um that's why I became
the wrestler cuz he's like [__] it
probably would have ran the light anyway
you know
probably would have ran the light
[Laughter]
anyway we had there running the light 10
minutes great I was yeah I was in line
at some point whether you shot this load
in 94 or 98 I'm coming out like a men
and black sequel baby this is the '90s
partying the city till the heat is on um
and uh yeah so I uh I always had a I had
a weird upbringing and um when I was
like 11 years old I got into Michael
Jackson we were coming back from a
karate tournament and uh fat by Weird Al
came on and I didn't understand what
the big man big man what well no guys
that's all right thanks I don't want
anything um dingdong man ding dong ding
dong
yo like I didn't I haven't thought of
that God I haven't either it just hit me
as soon as you said
it time and then he just does the move
and then he
gets and like my dad was like if you
want to know why this is so funny cuz
Okay so that's what I wanted to say you
didn't get introduced to Michael Jackson
you you went
reverse yeah like I listen to weird out
first and my dad was like if you want to
know why this is funny go home and watch
Michael Jackson's Bad and then I did and
then my life got separated into two
chapters like I was as equally obsessed
with weirdal as I was with Michael
Jackson like and I would go on the
talent shows performing as Michael
Jackson like wig shirts you could do the
Dan has did it all I started when I was
13 and I did it till I was like 16 did
you really uh so I did it for about
years you make money at it and stuff
like winning contest or I would do uh a
lot of talent shows and I put on a lot
of my own concerts um where I can
moonwalk and [__] I used to be able to
now that R is knocked off it wasn't I
don't know who let me do it for as long
as I did like it's I was good in socks
yeah really like I'm wear like whole ass
my grandmother would take me to Calvin
Klein to get penny loafers and like or
Lord and Taylor that's be wearing like
lordon Taylor penny loers with like the
ankle high Sox and I would not only
dress like that in performance I would
go to school dressing like that like
that was my whole that was my every day
that was my sense of style and uh my you
dress like Michael
Jackson you're 10 11 whatever what year
is that this is 20 20 because I grew up
in the Michael Jackson [__] and that's
the 80s this is 20 some years later it's
affected you
you're dring like I was yeah and like
this is before he died too so like and
this was maybe 2005 is when I would say
it started for me like right when the
his second trial was over somehow the
universe had just given it to me that's
like I remember you were pre you were
pre was pre pre Michel I had the zipper
jacket in the glove you [__] on
top of the car
Dancing never wore I had parachute pants
and a Michael Jackson jacket and I my
grandmother my mom's mom got them for me
I'll never forget this and I never [__]
I hated him I never put them I was
they're not practical parachute also in
my neighborhood if I put a Michael
Jackson jacket on and I walk outside
before I walk outside my brother's going
to beat the [__] out of me and then the
rest of the neighborhood I'm not even
getting out of the house with that video
on my [__] face yeah that was going
to happen to me too when I lived in a
retirement community they're just going
to beat your ass either way wait you
lived in a retirement Comm oh God damn I
was say we got a lotel s where do you
think the crack was coming from it was
coming from Hunter Biden baby thank you
he was coming to visit popac once a week
we get long curly wig I had the wig um
in my later years I had the glove I had
costume changes I had all of it costume
in school yeah I mean like I would put
on I see you in first period when I see
you after lunch are you no shirt on I'm
just going to be like rocking this [__]
am I even having on this pod might like
have I don't know see how it works out I
might do this like halfway through we'll
just see what's going on my aist
tour so much that by the end of this CL
it's going to be like strip poker I'm
just going to be sitting here and be
like yeah and this is where my dad stuck
his other Fingers um it's the it's the
clothes lines that he didn't hit that
stuck with you I had costume changes
through schol I could remember my
[__] lunch you
got backup Blazers I had [__] my lockers
Blazers oh man I had F like okay so
here's my question then why do you stop
what makes you go all right when you're
going to prom and you're like with your
date and you're like where'd you get
that eyeliner is that Maybelline I might
have to start using that on stage cuz
like mine runs and yours looks great um
and that's I'm also smoking crack at
this point too when I'm tired um come
there's a few layers so it's layered you
got to be doing one to do the other so
hold on I got to say this I'm going to
be honest with you if smoke a crack got
you out of your Michael Jackson face
there's a silver lineing I it kept me in
it for as long as I I don't know I don't
know if it got me in or it got me out it
did get me it did help me through the
Whitney Houston pH I well say that
because when she died I had a Whitney
Houston face and when she died I was
like nearing the retirement of my
Michael Jackson Career and I was
processing her death and then like two
months later my uncle died and then I'm
hanging up the glove so like there's all
these moving parts and I'm on
crack I'm 16 and I'm like why won't
anybody it was I was on cack and like I
would be I'd be up at I don't know how
my parents didn't know I would like be
coming downstairs at like 3:00 in the
morning and like cleaning [__] that
didn't need to be cleaned and like
talking to my I'm already manic as is
and on crack you were literally on crack
and it started because my uncle moved in
with us and he's a huge Michael Jackson
fan my dad doesn't like he hates that he
unleashed the Kraken on me right like
literally literally the Kraken
bro dude it was
I'm sweating I got to give you the I me
here is a sales [__] he comes up to me
and he goes do you want to try cocaine
and I said I don't want to I'm on I got
allergies this your uncle my uncle and
you're 15 I'm 15 the first thing he
offers me was oxycotton why though why
what made him come up to you and be like
cuz he was [__] cool no it was uh I
think they call it grooming I think
that's what was going on yeah um and I
had a tumultuous relationship with my
dad that drove me into the arms of the
cool uncle that you don't realize until
years later like oh that was a lot of
really bad [__] that actually isn't
normal but um so he comes in he moves in
with us cuz he lost his house because he
was a crackhead I was going to say and
he moves into my room which reminds me
of the line from The Boondocks where
he's like all the goddamn beds in this
house why'd you have to put the
possessed dude in mine godamn it like
why you got to be in my bed that's how I
felt at first we're sharing a bedroom
together how old is 50
I thought you were going to say your 20s
or 30s no he's 50 he's 12 years older
than my dad yeah he's you right now
right now this is some real Neverland
[__] happening like I was mcau culin in
this case there's another there's
another that's what I'm saying like and
M like came out was like Michael never
[__] me um but in this case so he
comes on in my room and he's like hey
take take some of these pills it'll be
cool you should get high and then he's
like do you want to try Coke and I was
like I I don't want to snort it I don't
want it to go up my nose and he's like
we could smoke it and it it's better
than cocaine there's no side effects and
uh it feels better than sex and I hadn't
had sex at that point but I heard a lot
of great things so I was like let's try
it and it was April 15th 2011 wow it was
the first day of my I remember my I was
we were on spring break and I was
supposed to be doing some report about
Mesopotamia and I remember he came home
with a bag of crack uh and then we went
on a car ride um and he he was he was
hitting the pipe and I was just like
trying to get in there it was like
double dutch I was like when are you
going to sh this was like the big day I
had like C my smoking it in the car and
driving like we're
going he went to go pick up his Oxy
Cotton pills so he could sell them and
flip them for crack we were going to do
[__] oh that's not even the that's the
beginning of it um about a year later uh
so that night I come home and like he I
kneel down I had like a desk that was
about this height in my room and he's
sitting at the desk and I kneel down in
front of him and he like puts the pipe
up to my lips and then I just I I inhale
I take it and then I'm immediately
hooked and uh what' it feel
like um is there a way to describe it I
you're also 15 getting a hit a crack
getting a hit a crack at 15 I have an
addictive person you smoke weed or
anything prior to that were you drinking
that so the first substance you ever put
in your system was CRA j a lot p.m. I
started doing that when I was like
12 yeah I was balanced it just kept me
normal it was weird I was just killed I
was even before a beer or anything I
smoked crack in April I didn't smoke
weed until that July out of a Bud Light
Lime can that I tacked did the thumb
tacks with I didn't even have a lighter
I had a birthday candle and a gas stove
so I took the birthday candle and I
brought it downstairs and I was like
holding my hand with it and I'm like
hitting it with the yeah and fresh prin
is on and our basement TV in the
background with no sound and I'm just
like watching Will Smith do this as I'm
smoking weed and I'm addicted to crack
um and and about six months later my
uncle gets kicked out because he comes
home and he's like I need you to take a
piss test for me comes and picks me up
from the doctor and takes me to the
doctor's office they're like where have
you been for the last hour you're
supposed to go in that room and take a
piss test now you got to go in that room
and do a blood test my uncle's 50 and he
tries to convince me to comb my hair
back put on glasses so I'll look like
him and go there and take the blood test
for him do you look anything like each
other at all I have way more teeth he's
black and uh he is my my dad is black uh
and this is on my dad's side but my
uncle is my complexion and so we kind of
looked alike but I don't look 50 like
I'm a six I'm 15 you're a child I'm 15
16 years old yeah um and uh so like I
call my mom in the bathroom and I'm like
Mom you got to come pick me up like this
is going I don't know what to do and
like my parents didn't know they didn't
know I was on drugs so I told them maybe
when I was 24 cuz I didn't get off coke
coke until I was 3 years ago 3 years ago
last month was when I stopped doing I
stopped smoking crack at 18 but I still
snorted a lot of blow until about 24
holy [__] so you smoked crack for three
years I mean through your [__] yeah
through high scho sorry your your
influential high school years every day
um as often as I could get it and uh and
are you like SL sneaking out of school
to do it or anything or you able to
maintain like around school hours you're
good yeah I was able to keep business
and and uh and and and no one knows you
don't end up smoking with friends you
don't bring anyone in no so threee
secret of just you and your uncle well
he died a year into me smoking um what
yeah he when I was 16 he died and then
while he was living with you uh he got
kicked out after my mom found out that
he tried to get me to do the blood
testing and then about 6 months after
that he died and uh I remember calling
his ERS what what did he die from was it
an overdose he was diabetic and crack
takes away your appetite and he didn't
he would get high for several days and
then not eat and there was a few times
where I walked into him in my room like
in a diabetic coma essentially just like
still frozen because you're high and
you're not eating and your blood sugar's
low and when he died I blamed myself for
a lot of years because I felt like a I
got him kicked out and B I wasn't there
to save him and that's what I think kept
me on drugs for as long as I was um and
it wasn't until I was 18 I was working
this restaurant job uh as a bus boy and
I came home on my 18th birthday watching
Drake host SNL and he was doing a cat
Williams impression and somewhere the
chemical connection of Cat Williams
Drake and crack just made me be like I'm
never gonna make it if I keep smoking
this [__] CU I was doing comedy for like
maybe six months at that point I started
when I was 17 um and then um yeah I I
stopped smoking it at 18 I snorted it
till I was
24 but I didn't really pick it up again
till I was like 21 um and then Co really
expedited it because then we're all just
home you know for where I I lived with
three Irish bartenders who and so now
we're all NTI guys who are home and Joe
Biden's giving us all this cocaine money
so we're going to do some cocaine we
were getting the Trump stimulus checks
um where he would sign him so great
stimmy I got that that blow stimmy um
and uh I got off coke through Buddhism
that's how I found out about it because
I started Med right downstairs yeah yeah
yeah there's uh it was just mindfulness
I never really learned mindfulness and
meditation and learning why I'm doing
something you know
like why like I never because my life
just had moved so fast that I never
stopped to think why something was
happening and if your life is a complete
roller coaster maybe you're the common
denominator and start to think why
you're the common denominator and
there's good days and there's bad days
and there's um you know I'm a LIF long
addict essentially um I a lot of the
time it feels like I got corrupted like
uh Anakin Skywalker and and the
Chancellor Palpatine you know but you
really did crack to a kid I crack until
I was a kid man yeah costume change I'm
sorry yeah I did it for there goes my
crack Li I still carry the blow torches
with me this is the only one that I
could get out there yeah man like I came
on this podcast for a couple this is
kind of like what the first pipe looked
like I'm not even kidding like the the
the thing would be out great
advertis and then it'd be a thing on top
with like a a tin foil cover and it was
like plugged and then you okay so and
then you go downstairs you're not even
smoking out of glass pipes or anything
your uncle's got once he died I did he
had his own custom I he have a rig or
something yeah you get 15% off using
promo code Rock and you just smash
somebody's car window and take it from
them uh he had his own custom crackpipe
rig that was insane now that I'm
thinking about that that is an insane
thing to have he was a professional it
had it had its own little bag it was a
custom little B it was like it looked
like an asthma inhaler but made of
marble um and then I discovered the
glass stems the rose pipes and that's
when you're really a crackhead so he
dies and you said you reached out to his
dealers cuz that's what I want to know
where's a kid continue to get cracked
deers they came in they I was going out
to make the drops for him when he was
living for us so I had a relationship
with a lot of them okay so I want to
talk about that in a second too you were
going on runs with them all the time I
want to talk about some [__] you saw cuz
I know it's it's crack story so it's got
It's not normal [__] hey John yeah it
was but wait real quick they're they
have they know you're a kid and they're
still giving it to you they don't care
well after he dies yeah one of them I I
I they came up to a do a delivery and
the guy was like you got stop smoking
this [__] man this will kill your uncle
man and weigh $60 and then just get the
hand off I'm like 16 I go right back
inside put on Dirty Diana and I'm
getting hot the one you were listening
to dirty D that might have been the one
that started it and then I ended with
blam It on the Boogie and then I'm just
being like I'm cold um and so he said
that you remember the guy saying that I
remember him his name was Shawn uh and
he was scary I had a scar like up my
kidney for a while cuz like he he like
tried to jab me with a screwdriver cuz
my uncle shorted him like
$23 he like to go stab me with the
screwdriver I don't think he meant to
but then like it just like went up my
and like I I was wearing a white shirt
like this and my dad was on the front
porch and I came inside and he's just
sitting there like it sounds like
bleeding out the side and he's like did
you take the trash out I'm like I will
let me go patch myself up with a gorilla
glue my uncle was also bisexual and uh
would go to uh uh truck stops a lot um
and there would can I ask you this yes
was he bisexual before the crack
happened there was crack either way
brother it just depends on he needed
that crack he's going to go to truck
stops and get that job he was yeah it's
going to happen um my grandfather his
dad was very religious and kicked him
out for being by I honestly think he was
gay um but uh he kicked him out for that
and he he went into the arms of drugs
and inevitably died because he wasn't
allowed to be who he was that's why I I
mean like it feels very sanctimonious
talk about stuff like homophobia on
stage but I I come from it thinking what
would have happened in my life what
would have happened in his life if he
got to be the person that he was and
didn't have to feel ashamed of of that's
cuz that's you probably would you
probably wouldn't smoke smoke crack I
don't think that there's a reason I
don't a hug a hug would have set that
ship on the right
cor you get one hug or 10 years of crack
yeah you either going to yeah man it's
I'm gonna take the 10 take I'm G take
the 10 cuz you don't have as many nearly
hug stories as you do crack stories how
many hugs landed you in a truck stop
[__] how many fun funny hug
stories you got I've had a lot of funny
hugs but not in the haha way it's more
like oh this very Catholic truck stops
and like I would be in the car that's
also a Sure Fire way to be murdered too
you know and I was just alone in the car
while he's
like doing [__] with dudes in the back
of their trucks I'm just sitting there
oh you're wait you're with them for that
part you're on the you're just like
leave in the car yeah I'm like I'll stay
here with the crack no every time
happened about five or six times there
was just a lot of stuff like that where
like you're sweating like a crack ad I
am I know I mean I can't imagine how
much of a [__] I look like right now
this is probably so bad you've never
opened up like this going need a second
shower I know oh my God this is so bad
this is what I look like in the Michael
Jackson
days God you look good I all black so I
wouldn't sweat and now by the end of
this podcast like I don't know what the
[__] I'm doing I feel like this is all
happening again I'm
being get the crack pipe guys get the
crack pipe the farmer's dog was founded
by two dog lovers who decided to
reimagine pet food from the ground up
and in the first five years since they
delivered their first meal the response
has been incredible the farmer's dog
isn't just fresh high quality food they
also send the food pre-portion
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs this makes it
easy to help your dog maintain their
ideal weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life a
fresh diet has been found to have all
sorts of benefits from healthier coat
and skin a better breath even easier
digestion it doesn't matter if your dog
is young or old it's always the right
time to begin investing in their health
helping you live more healthy happy and
full years together look I told you
we've been pumping Farmers dog they're
they're awesome they they tailor each
you get turkey chicken I think there was
a beef one uh there's so many different
ones they put their dog's name on there
Princess Lily Rose here's her feeding
guide right here as well everything's
spelled prop look at her she's tearing
this up she is tearing it up she I had
to put her outside to do another ad and
she's clawing at the door get
50% off your first box of fresh healthy
food at thefarmersdog.com Honeydew plus
you get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com honeydo to get 50% off
that's
thefarmersdog.com
honeydo you don't have to be an athlete
to need extra hydration throughout your
day from Zoom meetings to long travel
days or fun nights out liquid Ivy makes
it easy to stay hydrated their hydration
multiplier comes in three delicious
sugar-free flavors you got white peach
green grape and lemon lime a proprietary
zero sugar hydration solution with no
artificial sweeteners look we have
liquid liquid Ivy has been running with
us for a long time now we love liquid IV
we support liquid IV we all use it here
at the studio we got tons of it out
there for our guests my neighbors are
always hitting me up for it liquid IV is
also great I'll just tell you they send
me bags of this stuff bags all right I
love it we all use it we're out there
running around everybody's better off
with liquid IV one stick of liquid IV in
16 ounces of water hydrates better than
water alone with three times the
electrolytes of the leading sports drink
no artificial sweeteners and zero sugar
Plus contains eight vitamins and
nutrients for everyday Wellness grab
your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid i.com and use code honey doit
checkout that's 20% off of anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com now let's get back to the
D um oh God damn yeah but that teaches
you grit that's why I made in this
business um and I like that you talk
about the highlighting the the low
lights because there's nothing think
about like the comics that you know most
Comics have had horrible in things that
most human beings suffering to a level
could not deal with would ruin them
would ruin them and that's why they're
successful what happened to your uncle
right yeah exactly there's plenty of
people who have been unaccepted and
taken their own lives in a way whether
it's immediately or slowly over time
right and there's that's what I love
about this show I fell in love with
Comics all over again cuz it's there's
no one that can come and sit in these
seats and tell you [__] like this right
15-year-old smoking crack like I know
what happened to me at 15 and I I'm
still they they say I I don't know
exactly saying but they say if there was
a circle of people and we all throw our
problems in the middle we'd all take our
own [__] right back and I'm telling you
even though I know what happened to me I
ain't [__] smoking crack at 15 yeah
you know so it's it's you also you're
mentally tough and to be able to laugh
at that [__] like because it's it's you
either cry all the [__] time yeah or
you figure out a way to be like what I
mean what the [__] we to do here and I
definitely and you've turned it into a
career that gives back and helps people
you know what I'm saying like I do that
patreon and when I hear some of that
[__] I'm like the [__] am I bitching
about and also like you develop a
community with those people um because
they don't it takes one person to share
that story right and then the rest of
the people like people come up to me uh
people came at the improv show I did
last night and they brought me like I'm
a huge comic book nerd they brought me
like this giant Batman poster they
brought me some Wolverine Pez and they
brought me like a couple of Lego Clone
Troopers check that Pez don't
cut that sh it's great you got more that
pants candy I'll take a cough drive if
you got it something I'm going feeding
Jerry got some uh I don't know anybody
got a Rola something yeah come on we
used to do Smarties back in the Smarties
that's that's you crush them up right
sort I smoked them right in there with a
big not Smarties yeah it was PCP
actually the whole time did you have PCP
too no so was it just crack and weed and
weed crack didn't really smoke a lot of
weed until no cigarettes I did then that
gets expensive I did I still do
cigarettes um but I started smoking
cigarettes when I was like 16 okay um I
tried when I was like 13 but it just
made me horny every time I smoked I
would just get like so horny yeah so
phallic and I would just be like Bo and
like I remember I was steal my mom's
cigarettes and like go upstairs and
watch Planet of the Apes and I'm like I
shouldn't be horny watching this with a
cigarette hanging out of my lips um and
uh yeah it's the the res there's nothing
this business can do to you that life
hasn't done and that's why you look at
the people who are successful in this
and why they are successful there Ain
nobody online that can say [__] worse to
me than my own mother has there Ain
nobody nobody online that says more
racial slurs on Call of Duty than you do
dog that's it Ryan Slicker with a hard
R both times and not where you think it
is all right so you go on runs you sit
and wait with the crack while your
uncle's making earning his money ear his
money I watched him make you ever ask
him about it you be like what did you
just do in there would he ever tell you
yeah in great
detail he wasn't lying say no no no I
remember when he told me he was bisexual
uh we were at a place called Al's hot
dogs I'm not even kidding I'm not even
kidding it's Al's hot dogs in Nagata
Connecticut it's still open every time I
go home which isn't often I have to just
divert my eyes because I just I it used
to be like Vietnam every time I Clos my
eyes I would just I would see the hot
dog I got a foot long that day I don't
know why I had
the
overall when and one of the straps are
off you just see nipple and I'm about to
take a bite out of a hot dog and he's
like you knew your uncle was bisexual
right and I'm like horrible timing my
brother horrible time wait for the
mustard to touch my lips and then I
don't think I've touched a hot dog since
and if I have it's been Fe away um been
the little tiny ones um and uh yeah I
was doing the drops I was doing I did it
all and like it uh what do you mean are
you driving at that point now I still
don't have my license okay so you're
just rolling with him I'm I'm like going
down stre robbed you ever get attacked
you ever get threatened I [__] never
physically I got attacked at one time
with the screwdriver I don't think he
meant to jab me um and then there was
that time there was a time where like I
was supposed to give a guy uh like four
or five pills and I think I gave him 10
instead and of course he didn't turn
back around be like hey sorry there was
a misunderstanding fellas I think he
gave me six more than I
need what a genuine fell half a dozen
extra and then my uncle was so pissed at
me that um he was like like oh God my oh
my and then so he made
me you killed me TR that's
$120
and he made me go to school and I had to
start looking for people who were going
to buy them from kids other kids who
were like I was a freshman so I was like
going to Target like and I grew up in
the part of Connecticut that started the
opioid crisis I probably have something
to do with it I'm looking back at it I'm
up there with the sackers um and uh yeah
I remember leaving one deal one one time
I rode my bike across town to go make a
deal uh as I was leaving that deal I saw
my other Uncle my mom's brother who was
a addict at the time he no longer is and
he's alive shout out to my Uncle Neil
way to go Uncle Neil and uh he was like
Hey you know where I can get some uh
some more of those pills and I'm like
it's the tail of two uncles they're both
drug addicts and like I get back on do
they know each other they do know each
other um and they know that um they know
who what what they're up to like when I
was when I was like 12 my uncle my on
the other side stole my brother's
Nintendo DS that my mom got him for
Christmas it was like hidden downstairs
in the basement and uh traded it to a
drug dealer uh for heroin and um my dad
found out about it and it was one of
those other situations like my dad came
home covered in someone else's blood
because he just walked up to Michael and
just pouned him like punched him right
in the face and just blood spurts
everywhere and he's like where is it
Neil Neils like say something boom does
it again where is it and uh two Neil's
credit and took two hits and he's like
all right this's exact address here is
where it is go get it and then uh they
got a [__] together it's been clean
since then um but it's it's it's weird
like because if you think about it I've
replaced one drug for another but the
one that I do now is a lot more
productive and it helps people and it
helps me comedy is is a lot like is that
weed for you cocaine no comedy and
cocaine I think are very similar um just
in the sense that uh the release very
short you're already on your way home
you're you're already on your way home
and um it's fleeting and then as soon as
you get home and you're alone you just
want to go out and do it again and
except this time you're doing it in a
way where you're developing a community
it's it's two-sided I get something from
my audience they get something from me
and uh when you're it's a way better
heroin CLE way better heroin than let me
tell it is way less uh I you would know
you would probably have you ever had
heroin I snorted it you did I would
snorted a bunch to try to come so let's
let's talk real here for a minute what's
a better High crack or heroin they're
different High one's going up and one's
taking you down right yeah one heroin is
bad because your body gets dependent on
it and you get really sick um not the
same way you do with crack you go
through crack withdrawals I would liken
them to like caffeine withdrawals like
you uh have three cups of coffee every
morning and then one day you don't all
of a sudden you start to feel those
headaches you feel everything heroin you
just feel sick and you know you don't
need it but your body needs it because
that once that goes in your your blood
chemistry that's over it's it like and
you don't even enjoy the act of being
high you just don't enjoy uh throwing up
and and and shaking and sweating all the
time uh you enjoy that a lot less than
you do um but I the crack withdrawals
would be so heavy that I would just try
a little bit of AG just to come down and
okay that was maybe for
about
that was on and off when I was 23 I
definitely sorted more than I did when I
was in high school but uh it's um do you
switch from crack to hero or you always
using crack at that time always crack
and then if I could get if the dealer
had any like a little bit of heroin like
not a lot I mean it's also cheap too and
uh you're lucky you're clean now this
fentanyl [__] is that's the other thing
too like you'd be dead I remember during
Co when the F all [__] was really
starting to spike up especially in the
city and I got I stopped doing blow
August 22nd
2020 um and that was everything and like
I'm seeing my friends that are out
partying now and I'm like dude you're
going to die you're going to die you are
going to die this is cuz like your drug
dealers don't give a [__] about you
you're on their time you tested it I'll
test yeah yeah yeah no I'm Co I wented
to go meet up with this weed guy once
and I was like what are you doing man
and he was like I was like what are you
doing down in Chinatown and he was like
oh I'm going to I'm going to pick up
some fentanyl strips and I was like oh I
guess I can and I thought he was joking
but then I was like oh yeah no you're a
drug dealer and I can never buy weed
from you ever again um so I it uh so
what makes you finally tell your parents
you hit rock bottom I was drunk when I
was like 23 home you didn't even want to
um you didn't have an intention to sit
down and say Mom and Dad this is what's
going on no because I didn't want them
to feel guilty about it but I also um
have been doing some standup bits about
it and I knew
that I think in the back of my head
I would rather they hear it from me
first rather than watch a bit and then
be like this was way too specific to be
a joke like this actually happened and I
a part of me wishes I never told them
because that can't be easy for a parent
to hear um and they do blame themselves
and and we are guil people say how do
you say it cuz you got to tell your mom
who you're also doing it with told first
yeah I told my mom um I think she knew
to some degree I think my dad knew that
something he he just didn't like the
relationship ship that him and my uncle
had the one that got me on crack um and
uh I I just sort of we were driving back
from my brother's eighth grade
graduation uh it's like maybe
2018 and my mom said some her and my dad
were fighting and then you know like
when you get older and your your parents
start revealing family secrets to you or
family does you're like holy [__] where
did that come from and I was like I
don't know why dad's like that all the
time and my mom went probably cuz his
parents were cousins and I was like what
what how old are you when you find that
out uh this was like maybe 5 years ago W
um there yeah I think they were like
maybe I don't know what the level of
cousins that's okay for to be but they
were but they weren't first cousins they
were not first they might have been
second or third um Gatesville County
North Carolina there's a lot of mattress
hopping a lot of family reunions a lot
of [__] happen at those family
reunions um and uh why go across town
when you can go across the hall that's
my family gene pool you know what I mean
um
so that's underneath your family arms
that's like where all the family members
are buried in the backyard just so they
can 69 each other in the
afterlife we bury our relatives face
down oh [__] um and uh I think after she
said that I was just kind of like yeah
you know I smoked crack with vent when I
was 15 right and then um my dad and I
cuz he kicked me out when I was in high
school say she get pissed and she say I
remember her being very quiet think it
was more like I think she knew and I
just confirmed it because she definitely
covered my ass once um my dad found my
journal and it was talking about uh the
drugs and like CU I would Journal a lot
when I was coming down and I would be
very specific and he found the journal
and uh called me downstairs made my mom
do a drug test uh next to me um and do
you have to pee or they take blood it
was the spit test oh spit yeah and I
like did blow two nights ago it's the
same as Coke it comes it shows up in
your system as cocaine so like someone
was on Tik Tok the other day and they
were like that's the cool thing about
crack man is like shows up on the drug
test and you don't know if it's cocaine
or crack so if it comes up as cocaine
just be like oh sorry I smoked a little
crack the other night I didn't know it
in the blunt it was in the blunt I
smoked a little crack um and it came she
was like yeah there's nothing in his
system he's not doing any drugs and I
that might have been true I don't know
how long it stays in your system for um
I do think that if she really did think
I was an addict that either one of them
would have stepped in at that age and
been like hey come on let's come help
you um but your brothers aren't [__]
with it or are they way too young no no
no no we don't have that much of a
different I have a brother who's two
years younger than me and one who's
eight years younger than me so the one
who's eight years younger than me was
way too young two years younger than
never had any intention with it no he
was on the Spectrum and he was really
into the Beatles so that's he was like
uh that was his thing and I was a crack
smoking Michael Jackson impersonator
godamn and now he's Ultimate Fighter I'm
yeah I'm in the interrogation sauna room
it feels great I'm I'm swe for parts of
my tips I know I I love it yeah um but
no I I it's easy to look back and then
go wow how did you you know this poor
kid I look back at it and I'm glad that
it happened when it did because I would
have experimented with drugs at some
point in my life at any stage it's on
both sides of my family it's in my jeans
and I would have experimented with it
and I'm so
glad it may have messed up my uh life
trajectory and brain chemistry I'm glad
I got it out of the way at an age that
seems inconsequential in comparison to
if I started getting into drugs now when
everything is going well for me in my
career you know like um because now I
know the consequences of it and I've
lost friends I've lost family members uh
I so do you feel like that has really
set you up for life where you're like
been there done that I don't even need
to [__] with that again yeah or do you
miss it no I don't miss it I think I did
the first few times I tried to get clean
and that's why you end up going back but
like I know I don't miss it weed smoking
weed doesn't make you want to smoke you
know what I mean the habit of smoking
again and taking it makes me want to uh
eat Gummy Bears um I Love Weed uh and it
I have a lot of chronic fatigue and
thank God that chronic be helping that
fatigue um and so like the weed is just
sort of like a blanket that's there for
me um but like I know I don't miss it
because I'll get done with shows and I
do meet and greet after the show every
time you know it's like you take
pictures with everybody they came to see
you you're going to show up for them
then by the time that's over the last
thing I'm thinking is all right I want
to go party I'm like no I want to go lay
in bed eat a pint of ice cream and then
just wake up and have diarrhea tomorrow
yeah give me some pizza sh dud I'm going
to lay in bed I'll flip through some
[__] Channel look at the internet go
to bed that's exactly what I want to do
where I'm at that's where I've always
been on the road though I've never been
like the Ric Flair guy go I got to party
with someone I got to I'm okay going to
the bar have fun most of America is the
same like all of America pretty much
looks exactly the same there's like
three cities that are your Home Depot
looks like this yeah right like even
when I was checking in my hotel Tuesday
in uh Korea Town in La the guy was like
I asked the guy what a good place to eat
around here and he was like 7-Eleven and
then I went on Google Maps and I was
like God damn he was not lying is that's
a good place to eat around here Kore
Town's got great places man go get
Korean barbecue I couldn't read them all
any of them I don't I I smoked crack
instead of taking that Korean class I
wonder how things would have gone
differently for me if I picked up a
Korean instead of the crack
Pike so what when you finally get clean
what happens um when I get clean when I
stop doing coke completely it's August
2020 I start meditating every single day
I read mid P heavy pandemic heavy
pandemic um I read this book by Robert
Wright called why Buddhism is uh the
true religion or something like that one
of those like aggressive titles um and
uh if you ain't Buddhist you ain't [__]
I read that one Larry the cam guy wrote
that one yeah um and then he also wrote
metaphysics for dummies this particle is
bigger than the other one metaphysics
for zombie and then you got the porn
parody of that Christopher Nolan movie
called slopen Heimer it's gross just
like instead of an atomic bomb he
invents AIDS
um
uh once I get I felt Clarity once I
finally stopped doing everything because
it was a time my life
where I was I was cognizant of why I had
the temptation to do what I wanted to do
and uh I downloaded a dating app uh I
started going on dates most of them
sucked but I was clean so I had to deal
with that and that was a level of of uh
film that I would put on top of it and
then about 3 months into being clean I
got into a relationship uh and that was
a big was someone who was also clean or
at least not smoking crack she was not
smoking crack that's what I was looking
for in a woman yeah that's clean enough
for me she has as many teeth as she does
hands that is a winner right there I
need somewhere to put this ring yeah um
I don't even care if she has all 10
fingers you can have six just have this
one yeah just you can have 10 on one
hand I don't give a [__] yeah right
there use that for me uh cuz I got two
of them um but uh yeah no it it was
really just about like changing who I
was surrounding myself with all the time
and also not uh hanging around with so
many co-heads and um cuz it's more or
less the recovery process that kills you
than the drugs itself right cuz like you
you stay up doing blow till like 700 in
the morning and you're going to sleep
till like 5:00 p.m the next day then you
haven't eaten for two days you're going
to eat McDonald's then you're going to
feel like [__] then you are going to
[__] then you're going to want to do
blow and it's just that cycle that's
just repeating over and over again
because those are the people that I had
to hang out with during a pandemic when
I couldn't go outside um um
and I was always worried that I was
going to go
back but luckily I've had this great Yin
and Yang in my life where things when
they're going really well I'll get
kicked in the balls and it makes it just
reminds you that like nothing is Perman
the pleasures we seek evaporate and um
having this that's a that's life boy oh
it's going good for you boom right there
I'm having a great time right here I
can't wait to get [__] in the ass by a
gorilla when I leave whatever insane
[__] going to happen I'm going to have
like a safe hit me in the head and just
drop me right down um but like yeah I I
feel um I just hit three years which I
don't like look at like oh I look at it
like wow that's the longest I've ever
gone in my life without doing every day
I don't do Coke is the longest I've ever
gone in my life consecutively without
doing it you know what I mean great and
um how do I feel I feel better knowing
I'm probably not going to die that way
you know like I would have hated to like
go out like a Pulp Fiction style thing
right you know like the adrenaline thing
and they got to stab you in the heart
and then everybody being like well you
not that you've seen that but you've
seen people die from this yeah people I
loved best friends um and how how were
you again when your uncle died 16 and
that doesn't scare you right then and
there enough right but you're addicted
so I think I think it did scare me and I
didn't know how else to deal with that
fear so I just went back to drugs I mean
that's it's masking and it wasn't until
I was in going into my senior year of
high school where I discovered comedy
again and I got really into late night
TV and I went back to watching Letterman
and Conan and um I was working that bus
boy job and I started doing comedy and
the more serious I got about comedy uh
the less series I got about getting high
and you have to face the same trials in
life at different poison in your life
sometimes right like getting off cocaine
at 18 was the same getting off of it
when I was 23 it's just what did I do in
those 5 years in between I moved out to
the city I built out career I just lived
through a pandemic still am living
through a pandemic and uh I'm I'm not
the same kid in high school I was now M
kid who's been out on his own for five
years and uh I have to face this trial
again but you because you've already
faced it I feel like a lot of the time
you run away from it because you're like
I already did I'm not ready to do this
work again man like come
on and now I just my biggest hindsight
looking back on all of it is when I
start to feel that thing of
comfortableness and I don't want to face
it I just open myself up to it
completely because that's the only way
to really deal with it is like okay this
is happening right now let's deal with
this problem like head on Square on
what's going on why do I feel this way
how do I not make this happen how do I
make myself uncomfortable again so I can
continue to to that's the only way you
develop yourself as a stronger person I
went on the dating apps when I got sober
because I knew I didn't want to go on
the apps and I knew they were going to
make me social um and it worked out and
um uh I feel Lu to have gotten out
um but also if I didn't do this for a
living I would probably feel undeserving
to have gotten clean um explain that
like if you just had a job as a plumber
right if I didn't have a yeah you would
feel what you wouldn't feel like your
purpose was big enough to over overcome
that to share or help inside of me
that's still yeah I still have that like
I've got to do something bigger
Grand I can't just stop doing crap yeah
I can't just stop doing cra I have to be
doing something else too and also just
to justify the shitty decisions and uh
Life Choices I made I get that if you're
going from crack addict to you know
regular job right it's maybe two jumps
you want to go [__] Leaps and Bounds
yeah that's what I did uh and I I
luckily had the career while I was
getting clean and while I was on drugs
what were you doing for money at that
time were you doing odd jobs or you just
selling or what you doing when I was in
high school or when yeah to get your fix
and how are you getting this [__] that's
a good question cuz the guy's like this
shit's going to kill you $60 yeah yeah
no I like I where are you getting that
60 stealing pawning um yeah a lot of
stealing mostly stealing from who stores
people stores what par what was your
move in stores how would you get out of
there I would just take some [__] and
and and walk the [__] right out yeah I
wouldn't even run out I would just walk
right out I cuz I don't look like the
kid was going to steal like I I would be
this sweaty
um
I hate that get a mop on a six that
sweaty kids back there looking at the
peanut
buttercups it just keeps getting
worse I feel like I'm being we're almost
done no I love it just like no cuz now
after this you look like you showered in
here dude I did this morning look like
you like I'm going to like hang out with
the with like a CEO after this and like
my childhood Idol like hey thanks for
joining me on Make A Wish man please
take a shower oh um yeah no but uh this
is it's better to it's better to be
sweating and sober than to be sweating
and on crack because like you'd be on
coke doing standup shows and I don't
know how like prior and Robin Williams
those guys did it cuz like I'd be like
six minutes to a set being like I'm
booked for an hour holy [__] this needs
to move a lot faster I just want yeah
cuz like you would do a hit and then 7
minutes later you want another hit and I
can't be like excuse me one second guys
so anyway um and uh I like being in an
uncomfortable situation where like maybe
you're sweating too much or you have to
meet someone who is a lot higher than
you on the corporate ladder like I
remember like meeting a head of a a
talent division of some Network and I
was high uh being sober and uncom not
that I'm a sober person you know I still
drink I still smoke weed um but when
you're on a stimulant like that and when
you're dependent on it everything in
life is way more Amplified and your
level of discomfort is and then you're
not thinking rationally and that's why
you become an addict you're just stuck
and you're just like the only thing I
know how to do is get high so I'm going
to keep doing that and not do anything
else I'm not going to learn a trade I'm
not going to sign up for IT Tech [__]
all that I'm going just get that's what
my thought process was like I'm just
going to sit here and get high until I
die um and luckily sometimes you just
got to go for a walk sometimes you just
have to go out of your little box I live
in New York so I live in a shoe box
apartment I pay way too much money for
um where I live but I'm paying for the
address and it's because what if I'm if
I'm going stir crazy I can just go walk
outside Lower East Side of Manhattan and
then I can go walk for 20 minutes by the
time I get home I forgot what I was even
mad about but it's something that you
really have to force yourself to do and
put yourself in an environment where you
could and I'm very grateful to be able
to do that a lot of people are stuck in
life circumstances where they can't get
out um I just try to put myself in
circumstances where I'm not backed into
a corner and um it's also just wild cuz
it's not like life LED you to this path
of seeking drugs for Comfort or anything
this person came in and just gave them
that's really what it was yeah you know
it's crazy to me it's crazy to think you
know it's I I mean I'm not comparing
this in any way but it's the same way
you could put religion in someone or
anything at that age like you you you're
such a blank template to do whatever you
want with for someone to introduce you
to not even weed he didn't even say hey
you want to sip a beer he went crack bro
yeah crack I do I I compare it to the
religion thing too it's interesting you
say that because I always Richard
Dawkins had a line um this book I read
where he's like there's no such thing as
a Christian Child there's no such thing
as a Muslim child there's a child raised
by Christian parents there's a child
raised by Muslim parents and there's a
child raised by crackhead uncles you
know and um a lot of the the stuff that
we have is due to the circumstance that
we have surrounding us and also
hindsight too like I didn't realize it
was wrong right of course until years
later where you're just like in when
when did that hit you when did it when
you really sit down I stop feeling
guilty for him dying uh because for
about 10 years I definitely blamed
myself for that why uh you felt you
could have saved them if you were there
you I could have saved him I felt like
it was my fault he got kicked out I felt
like uh because he got kicked out he
ended up getting high alone and that's
what led him to die and I'm talking like
a year ago I stopped feeling guilty for
this [__] wow just because I was like no
that wasn't right because I have a
brother it's about they ask if you have
nieces or nephews or anything you're
thing like I I I I have I have nieces
and nephews who are around the age I was
and I got to think do I even would I
even want to drink a beer around them
the answer is no because they they're
going to see that and and they're going
to and and I know what's in the blood I
know what's in our family one one drop
one little anything and then you're
going to be screwed so like I would I
would never do that and then once I
realized that I didn't kill him uh
everything just sort of went out of my
system and it was gone um you know you
miss them I listen to some music
sometimes and I'm like man I wish you
were you supposed to be here but then
I'm like most of the time I'm like I'm
glad you're cold in the ground cuz you
can't get any other people addicted to
crack that's right dude really though
like sometimes
like people are too far gone for a
change to happen there's only two ways
you end up when you're on drugs and it's
dead or in jail that's right uh and um
or the third one is you get off them and
then you end up in a pile of your own
sweat there's A4 cup of water in my
taint right now looks like a super slide
I know yeah you're not going to want
this at all there's
a I have my my second [__] the water
the second [__] the second plane is hit
the [__] the personal [__] second
plane is at the [__] all right we're
we're going to this has been look this
has been a [__] fantastic feel like
this a therapy session I really got got
more than sweat out of my system I got a
lot I'm going to ask you this very last
question and we're going to plug
whatever you want again and we're going
to get out of here but I told you at the
beginning before we record it advice you
give to your 16year old self and I'm
interested to hear what you have to say
cuz this [__] starts for you at 15 so
it's wild to be a year into this you
said something and I've been thinking
about you were like what would you tell
your 16-year-old self uh probably to put
down the
pipe that's all I've been thinking about
um but I think it was uh Quinta Brunson
who said somebody asked her that
question she was like what would you
tell your you're the most quy former
crackhead I think I've ever met in my
life it's like I know yeah me and the
Scarecrow from the whz yeah um
that's realizing of O you did The Wiz
dude I just I really yeah I wasn't even
trying to then damn I really am black
um uh I she said I wouldn't tell that
kid anything because that kid got here
um I wish I could have just told that
kid that it was going to be okay cuz
that kid was you remember what it's like
being 16 you know the trauma you go
through that I just remember being very
lonely and wanting to ask for help but
was too scared to and um I I wanted
someone just to be there to tell me it
was going to be okay uh and I if if
anybody I would have listened to at 16
telling me it was going to be okay it
would be the person I am today that is
the one person I know who I would listen
to because he would yeah like I have the
job I have now because of a dream I had
when I was 17 that is insane that
doesn't happen and like I I got to see
my dreams come true which NE never
happens for anyone um and in my in my
family uh and I have to remind myself of
that constantly and remind myself that
that 16-year-old kid made a lot of
stupid decisions but that 16-year-old
kid still is inside of me somewhere I'm
I I think I sweat out a good chunk of
him uh but he's still like frosty in the
greenhous over here right now bro just
your hat left on I know yeah that's
really all it is this podcast just going
to be the mic happy
birthday how do you do fell kids don't
smoke crack drink water listen to the
Honeydew podcast subscribe on patreon WE
blow up Gotham City Hospital ton at
midnight Batman cut that
promo dude thank you thank you for man
plug everything one more time troyon
live.com for all my road dates uh I'm
going to Toronto I'm going to so many
places I don't even know how I'm I'm on
the road a lot um I don't know when this
is coming out so check out my website
Troy Bond live first thing you see when
you go on that website is just the
splash of all my road dates um and my
social media Troy Bond 69 um on Tik Tok
and Instagram uh Troy hasola on Twitter
uh you sign up for my mailing list on my
website um so you could find out from
when I'm going to be in your hometown
you'll see that I'm going to be up there
um and my AOL account is white chocolate
96 yeah
a.com that do exist anymore I exists if
you believe in it is that right it's
right here you got to aim for the heart
aim for the heart bro yeah baby uh as
always Ryan sikler Ryan sikler on all
your social media come see me on tour
all tickets are available on my website
at ransler
[Music]
[Applause]
a